we did go through some downsizing in
specific areas in internationally we
we've done no downsizing in North
America but I thought it was it was done
quite well first we looked at we had a
new CEO we have a new CEO that join us
in January 08 and as part of our
strategy to be more competitive we were
looking at ways to be more efficient so
it wasn't a true downsizing because of
the economy its how can you make your
company more efficient so the company
has done many things first they they've
tried to find folks other jobs where
there are potential and mostly again
it's dealing with customers or on
projects but they've also done some
really unique things in offering very
key folks that may not have work right
now sabbaticals so I have a very good
friend of mine who's been with the
company for a long time and she just
took a three-month sabbatical so we do a
lot of unique things like that because
we do see that the market is going to
return
always retool yourself always learn if a
if an employee regardless of what title
what level what company if they're
constantly improving themselves
constantly looking at ways to get
training and education and this doesn't
have to cost you anything you can go on
the internet and learn just about
anything these days but if you
constantly are trying to better yourself
and improve your knowledge and
experience through education you're
going to be able to have all types of
opportunities at your fingertips even
now even in this down economy there are
people that are looking for right folks
to employ I certainly a.m.